we've got big bands like van Halen the
Eagles and the doors we have a tri-coat
chinese democracy like guns and roses
album living with one plus 40 years
we've got this incredible drum set
professional drum set the drums oh
really the harder you hit it the louder
your drum needs will be the really cool
thing about this comes as you can expand
them new guitar with a lot of new
features on it we've improved ikut ah
greatly coolest thing we've got is this
touch-sensitive strip that's over the
console TV and it gets a number of
Stanford fan battle of the bands tabela
bullpens system it is like fullness he
created together and actually create
music we want to create a real musical
experience 3 playstation 3 360 xbox 360
and a week relay station to position
guitar hero brooke otário world tour
pentax guitar hero rock band guitar hero
fan guitar hero fan
oh hi you know we've done a lot of
talking here on Game life about the
console wars but now there's a new war
it's the battle of the bands yes the
fight over which fake plastic toy drum
set you a grown adult be putting in your
living room this winter is about to be
waged between guitar hero world tour and
rock band 2 well the first big thing is
it's a full band play so we've got this
incredible drum set professional drum
set new guitar with a lot of new
features on it microphone you can play
together as a you know full four-piece
band play online play for you know van
verse fan battle of the bands you can
also have a full band career both
locally and online or anywhere in
between beyond that we have the music
studio in gh tunes so mutes to music
studio allows up to four people to kind
of keep creative together and actually
create music record it you're not only
making music but they're actually making
gameplay for people to actually play
either singular or as a band as well
make your song make your masterpiece
upload it to gh tunes and then share it
with the world well how long should kind
of go to philosophy of innovating and
then perfecting so about even back as
far as frequency amplitude we innovated
in in like the game space and then
perfected it to be the best thing ever
so a rock band we innovated by making
the most authentic band simulation that
you could possibly have and then in rock
band 2 we're perfecting that experience
we're expanding it across an amazing set
list you can out battle bands you can
have an expanded well to it and play
online it's really sort of the
perfection of what we what we released
last year we had a welter in the
original rock band which was touring
around the world and getting fans and
and right busy a rise to fame story
forming a garage bands being the world
by Carolina and we're expanding in
revenue by allowing people online to
play so I could have a friend in Seattle
I could be in lost it and we can play
together can play as a solo player we've
added the ability to hire staff member
so you can build up an entourage we
abandon it helps you out so you could
get a an accountant that so it gives you
more money or you can street team to try
and get more fans to your shows and we
have opportunities as well which are
things like PCP news the first thing
about the drum set is that its velocity
sensitive right so the harder you hit it
the louder your drum beats will be
that's really cool in the music studio
can be really expressive and it's not
just sounding like a pitter-patter of a
drum you know standard drum machine the
next thing is that we raise the symbols
up off of the snare and the two Tom's we
really wanted to have a like a very
realistic experience while your drumming
we've got a midion jack on the back of
the drum kit right so it's a wireless
drum kit you can plug any MIDI device
into that right so you can use a drum
machine you can use a hand kind of hand
sonic type drum device can use a
professional $3,000 role in Yamaha get
whatever you want plug it in there set
your MIDI channel 210 and you're off
we've quietened the drums because you
know everyone loved the drums we have a
lot of neighbors didn't like our drums
so they're much quieter we have a metal
reinforced pedal which is pretty much
guaranteed not to break unless you can
get through solid metal and the really
cool thing about these drums is you can
expand them so if you start off with
four pads and like learn the basics of
drumming if you want to add symbols you
can buy a symbol expansion and plug them
into your drums or you if you want to
like learn how to use a hi-hat in our
drunk Raynor you can get a symbol on a
second kick pedal and then learn how to
like play proper hi app using a drum
free we made a lot of modifications
improvements on the guitar but the
coolest thing we've got is this
touch-sensitive strip so you can use
that for for touch strumming right so
you don't have to strum anymore you can
just touch and play the frets and
anytime there's a sustained you can kind
of Y on there you can also use it for
tapping sections so certain sections of
songs that are tapping sections you
neither cap up here if you have an old
guitar or another guitar you can tap
down here or you can use the slide
mechanic which allows you to feel I kind
of catch the notes as they fall down
improve the guitar greatly it looks like
a real pen to strike us what you think
is incredibly important you want look
the fantasy of playing guitar you want
to hold a real instrument deal will like
to 58 or if you are learned guitar so
we've we've got a woodgrain finish on
the strat and we've have a strongest
rumba for the fret buttons and also auto
calibration so you no longer have to if
you like a crazy like theater setup in
adaptive like figure out the millisecond
timings for stuff you just hold the
guitar up to the TV and it gets a number
of salt perfect now both guitar hero
world tour and rock band 2 we're going
to come in big big boxes with their full
suite of instruments and cost upwards of
150 dollars but you can still get into
the music game this winter without
spending so much money or taking up so
much of your living room space Microsoft
has lips karaoke game Nintendo has wii
music which is just played with your
remote controls and if your personal
tastes in music run to la musica latina
Sega has samba de amigo
you